I think the most exciting part of what I
do right now is exactly the fact that
what we are doing is giving patients new
hope that we're looking at a disease
which is brain cancer that people have
looked at for hundreds of years and we
have not been able to understand and
we're finally perhaps beginning to
scratch the surface we're beginning to
look at an old asees with new eyes and
what new eyes are those is the fact that
within brain cancer there may be a small
population of cells that have the
ability to recreate the same type of
cancer which means that despite the fact
that we can actually do a perfect
surgical resection we can take a lot of
these tumor out these patients
eventually continue to progress perhaps
because we're leaving those small little
cells back there that are able to
recreate the whole tumor so our role now
is to understand those small cells we
don't look we're not looking at the
whole tissue that we're leaving behind
but we're looking at a special subset of
population of cells that we can
potentially affect that we can
potentially damage their ability to
recreate that cancer and I think to me
that's absolutely dynamite because it
may actually change the paradigm in the
way that we treat brain cancer
in the future the way that I use in my
vision is at every patient will be
treated slightly different depending on
their ability depending on their markers
depending on the kind of cells they have
in their brain right now the weather we
are categorized in brain cancer is in
different categories and we lump all
patients together in different
categories when in reality we are
beginning to understand that every
patient is different just like we're all
human but we have different
characteristics different personality
tumors are probably the same way and no
one single treatment can be tailored for
many patients you probably going to
individualize treatment and that excites
me the other thing that excites me what
will we do in the operating room and in
a laboratory is the fact that we're
probably open doors for other fields to
conceive the way to unleash the
potential of the brain if brain cancers
a disease that continuously has the
ability to grow there are many other
diseases in the human brain where we
need that grow like in multiple
sclerosis Huntington disease Parkinson's
disease so our role is to try to learn
from that abnormal growth so we can
apply that knowledge to people who need
growth and parts of the brain that are
thirsty or yourself
you